he sold a lot of tickets in Australia
this guy is coming up in the world not
just in comedy but in general 72 days of
pornography 72 days awful more
pornography 72 days if you guys smell a
full bag heard something when you walked
in oh yeah that's cool baby
we got CEO Vaughn man one of my favorite
people on of all time D'Avanzo all right
what's up man
you good nice to be here and thank you
guys for having me in your home and/or
it's beautiful here good to see here
good to see you guys are still operating
on a high caliber yeah everybody's doing
well now how do you do 72 days without
porn you know what you well I what I did
is up with the blockers on my phone
science they have these scientific
blockers and you get them and you put
them on your phone in your computer and
it keeps me off of pornography so I'm
not seeing all that spread and all of
that [ __ ] and everything because I was
masturbating all the [ __ ] on there not
to be rude yeah I was doing when I look
back a man even told me said well write
down what you were doing it out then I
wrote that and I look back I was like oh
that's what I was doing wrong you think
you're doing it more than the average
person I thought I was doing it out of a
habit so I would just be uncomfortable
and I wouldn't know what to do with
myself and so I go do that instead of
like yeah instead of just coping or just
having an ear just like it wasn't like
it used to be like oh man let me crack
out a little bit of this pornography
right now he got to the point where was
like oh dude let me just do this and
then do whatever I'd go on about the
rest of my day but came a weird thing oh
like it's bad habit so you did it once a
day you think no I was doing it maybe
five times a week making my body I guess
right like it's working Monday through
Friday yeah take off some of taking note
Thursday into a Sunday I didn't have a
plan and riot so it's like working at a
restaurant yes take shift
picture picking up a lot of shifts and
also then sometimes some days not nice
showing up from work yeah yeah yeah I
guess I can I get it yeah yeah because
III I too have I think a problem oh yeah
I've heard about that man and what do
you mean everybody knows it for one I
mean look what happened here girls I you
can I just G just jut jetted one in
there I bro
it might think drips dude it doesn't
shoot well that's what I heard the other
day the other day you guys said it's
like two guys climbing out of like a
truck that fell over on its side right
right it was like winning to two tickets
after winning skee-ball yeah just two
tickets come back but let me ask what
happens to your body like like cuz I
remember years ago I did I did um I
think 70 days without masturbating and I
know it was weird
I was wondering like what number hell
erases I now realize I had these on I'm
sorry yeah it wasn't like that I didn't
realize that I was like damn I was moody
when I was like William Moody and or
love you know it's funny actually man I
felt a lot more anger right they just
realize that cuz I've been feeling a lot
more anger recently and I didn't really
I can't really I have been able to
equate it too much and then I think some
of it could be you know not masturbating
I um come out I want to be honest with
you there is an edge to you as of late
yeah I always equated it that you are
like you have so much on your plate and
that you're kind of stressed out yeah
right but maybe now in retrospect if I
think about it it could be you not
masturbating as well yep yeah yeah
what's the endgame here front the
endgame for me you know probably have a
little family somewhere oh you know or
you mean tonight no I mean I didn't mean
like your whole life
oh yeah yeah I just met like this
masturbation
that's what I'm at right I just wanted
what you fart with it you wanna go for
the rage hump though it's just like you
know quitting cigarettes and not having
the nicotine you're just gonna be a
shitty person for first couple days and
then you know yeah